now Russia says Road and rail traffic
has resumed on the major Bridge
connecting Crimea to Mainland Russia as
we reported earlier it was damaged in an
explosion early on Saturday let's show
you where that explosion took place and
explain why it's significant the areas
shown in red are under the control of
Russian forces and their separatist
allies the Kirch Bridge is a critical
route supplying moscow's troops in
southern Ukraine and the naval Port of
Sebastopol
is now live from Moscow with more on the
Russian investigation into the explosion
the Kremlin once answers Muhammad what's
the latest on in the investigation
yes fully uh the committee the special
investigation invest their special
investigation committee that was
appointed on Saturday by President
Vladimir Putin started its work
immediately and divers went underwater
at six o'clock this morning looking for
Clues among the the distracted destroyed
parts of the bridge also above the water
line a lot of inspection going on and
hopefully something might come up from
that investigation later today according
to Russian officials on Saturday right
after that blast a number of officials
unofficially appointed at Ukraine as the
party to blame and as the party would
have which holds the responsibility
behind the blast for instance the head
of the Foreign Relations Committee in
the parliament State Duma he basically
said that he had no doubt Ukraine was
behind it and if proven officially the
punishment or the response should be
severe the head of the Crimean
Parliament appointed of course by Russia
he also said the the the the vandals the
Ukrainian vandals have been able to
reach our Bridge with their bloody hands
so that's a direct accusation against
Ukraine but until now no official blame
has been allotted and Vladimir Putin
gave the responsibility of secure the
security of the bridge and Security in
general for the supply lines the gas and
other supplies going to Crimea to the uh
federal investigation or Federal
Security Services of the Russian
Federation Russia is trying to take its
time before it officially announces who
was behind this blaster against the
bridge in Crimea thank you for that
update Mohammed Val live there in Moscow
namuna on the power cut at the Ukrainian
russian-controlled zaparization nuclear
power plant that forced it to switch to
emergency generators joining us live on
the NewsHour from Vienna is Robert Kelly
who's a distinguished fellow at the
Stockholm International Peace resource
Research Institute and a former nuclear
inspections director at the iea thank
you so much for joining us the iea has
issued several warnings about the threat
of a nuclear meltdown at these
aberration nuclear power plant over the
past several weeks now we understand the
plant has lost its last remaining
external power plant and it switched to
backup diesel generators
how concerning is this first
the quality of the reporting we're
getting is very poor what we see is that
there are four major power lines leaving
the plant and when the plant is
operating it sells electricity over
these 750 000 volt lines all four of
those lines have been cut therefore the
plant can't produce electricity and sell
it and so it's been shut down what it
needs is some smaller lines that come
from a nearby coal burning plant to keep
its safety systems going and as far as
we can tell those are working the idea
that it's on a generator is a little
misleading as well there are 20
generators on this site Each of which
has enough fuel for 10 days they can be
shared between the six units and any one
generator can keep any one plant cool so
the the hysteria that's going on about
the danger of what's happening is is
quite overstated okay so you think
there's a bit of Hysteria going on yet
but explain to our viewers if you can Mr
Kelly why a continuous source of power
is necessary to despite the fact that
all six reactors of the plant are shut
down
all sex reactors are shut down ones have
been shut down for over six months uh
the problem is that after a nuclear
plant shuts down heat continues to be
produced for many months from the
radioactive decay in the fuel and
there's enough heat there that if you
don't cool it with water at a low level
compared to when it's running producing
power the plant will begin to overheat
the fuel can be damaged and the fuel
could even melt if it's not cooled after
a few days so it's it's very important
to keep it cooled but it doesn't require
a tremendous amount of electricity to do
that and the nearby cold burning plant
supplies enough enough electricity for
that person you said there is enough
power from the generators there are
several of them you said for 10 days but
what happens after after that
what you know what what is uh you know
if the diesel generators fail after 10
days are we looking at an immediate
meltdown
I think that's that's really overstating
the problem because there are 20
generators Each of which has enough fuel
for 10 days you're probably looking at
closer to 40. it's very hard to
understand that they would not be able
to supply electricity from a coal plant
that's two kilometers away uh during
that time they've had to deal with this
problem several times remember that this
plant is worth about 40 billion dollars
so the Russians want it as a war prize
and they want to have it intact so they
can use it after the war and the
ukrainians know that it's their property
and they want it after the war so
whoever wins the war wants this 40
billion dollar plan at the intact I
think that gives them plenty of
incentive to keep the plants safe and
cool yeah I was going to ask you about
that the significance and importance of
this plant and you talked about hysteria
there do you think that also has a role
in in everything that we're hearing
about what's happening at uh it's
operation right now
there's no question that the plant could
melt down all nuclear plants could melt
down and that's why they're designed to
not melt down and they have redundant
sources in this particular case we've
gone further down the safety chain and
there are fewer redundant sources than
there used to be but I think there's
plenty of energy in the region and from
the generators to keep this plant cool
until somebody wins the war and takes it
as a prize all right thank you so much
for talking to us thank you for your
Insight Robert Kelly former director at
the iea joining us there from Vienna
nice to be with you